okay is Apple really giving away magsafe
to Android so if you've been wireless
charging pretty much anything for the
past 15 years there's a good chance
you've been using something using the
chi standard so I don't know where we
get this press release announcing G2
which is an update which is supposed to
be much more power efficient and adds
magnets so it turns out Apple has
effectively collaborated with the
wireless power Consortium to contribute
the foundations of magsafe to the
standard which is these magnet arrays so
anything that's G2 certified will use a
specific array and strength of magnets
to meet the standard including potential
future Android phones yes so why would
Apple do this well two theories one is
we do see apple slowly moving towards
potentially not having a port at all in
the iPhone so if they can slowly Usher
the entire industry towards wireless
charging and that's a win for them but
then number two is just control because
let's be honest if apple is contributing
to the standard then they will have a
lot of influence over how it works so
while magsafe is a little bit more than
just the magnet array they are
effectively giving it away yes and I'm
also looking forward to snapping Android
phones in place on wireless chargers yes
please